turning now to a new memoir by amanda
klutz the wife of the late broadway
actor nick cordero
the tony nominee lost his battle with
the coronavirus last july
after spending 95 days in the icu
amanda helped inspire tens of thousands
of people to rally around him on social
media
she shared updates on his fight and led
daily sing-alongs to his song
live your life
[Music]
now amanda's sharing their story in her
new memoir live your life
my story of loving and losing nick
cordero she wrote it with her sister
anna klutz amanda who is also a co-host
of the talk on cbs
joins us now amanda good morning thank
you so much for being with us
i know this book has to have means so
much to you
and you started it i think a couple of
months after you lost nick
why was it important for you to to take
on this
good morning thank you guys for having
me today
you know i started it two weeks after
nick passed actually
um i was back in ohio with my family
kind of taking some time
just to kind of process everything and
um
you know i'll tell you what i don't
think i could write this book now when i
started this
uh you know putting everything down on
paper everything was just so
in the front of my mind you know the the
the doctors the medical
terms the numbers the machines and
it just honestly felt so good to
write it down to get it out of my head
and put it on
to well i'm going to say paper but on a
keyboard to my laptop
it was extremely therapeutic and really
cathartic just to kind of uh take that
trauma and put it down on
on a piece of paper and your sister anna
joined you what was that process like
you know honestly i don't think i could
have done it with anyone else anna was
with me
for the 95 day battle with nick she also
was with us in new york she she was kind
of like our third wheel our whole
relationship she was on part of our
honeymoon with us
and not only that she was but you know
she's my best friend and
uh we speak telepathically she is my
right arm
um and she was in paris and i was in los
angeles and because of the time
difference we honestly
were writing almost in 24-hour cycles
i would go to sleep she would be waking
up i would send her chapter she would
wake up work on those chapters she would
go to bed i would wake up and i would
start writing again
so someone was working on this book
constantly which is i think
why we were able to write it in six
months which is
i've learned because this is my first
book that that's unheard of that's a
miracle that's what it is it's six
months
amanda you know i remember watching your
journey on social media and on this
program you know as nick was going
through his battle and
i was so struck by your positivity what
was your secret for maintaining that
attitude and what's your advice for
people who are
grieving loved ones lost during this
pandemic
you know um thank you so much the the
head doctor
uh dr david ing he and i just became
like war buddies through this battle
and day one he told me he said amanda if
we look at this in a positive light
there's possibilities and if we look at
it in a negative light we have no
options and that is in the book and
i always have lived a positive lifestyle
i start my day
every morning with a positive thought
and i put it on my instagram stories to
share with all my followers
but that just really stuck to me and it
still does today
and um you know i think grieving is
is tough it is a road that you can only
go
on yourself it is a roller coaster it is
ups and downs and twists and turns
one minute you're smiling and laughing
and the next minute you're in tears and
you really
can't explain it and it's just it's a
tough road but i really do think that if
you can find
one thing a day one thing that keeps you
happy
one thing that makes you smile by the
end of the week you have this beautiful
bouquet and you just have to find
those little things throughout this
journey amanda that's a beautiful way to
put it
it's tony here we said earlier in the
broadcast that uh we're approaching 600
000
deaths due to the coronavirus you're
certainly one of the best known families
to have gone through that terrible loss
but there are so many others out there
i'm curious
as you were writing this book did you
have a sense that you were
you had a duty to represent what all
those other families were going through
as well and if one of those families
should pick up the book what do you hope
they get from it
i thank you you know tony yes absolutely
that crossed my mind
it's impossible to write this book and
not think about the loss that
you know the world has had from
coronavirus and
and it's just heartbreaking it's
absolutely heartbreaking
and i never thought in writing this book
i would feel like
that i was kind of writing nick's
closure to his story
but i really do believe that in writing
this he now knows
everything that happened to him because
he didn't know
i never let him know really any of the
negative things that were happening on a
daily basis
that roller coaster ride in the icu was
so tough
um you know i just think that we have to
keep moving forward we have to still
wear our masks and and try to socially
distance and just be careful and get
your vaccine
and as we slowly come back into the
world
you know just don't forget where we were
a year ago
and how things have changed and it's
wonderful to see i mean to see chicago
like that i mean i honestly was almost
in tears
but also it's crazy to think where we
were just
a year ago how different our lives were
amanda we've we've got to go but i
want to thank you for joining us i also
want to mention we saw pictures of elvis
who just turned to your son
he looks great as well thank you so much
for being with us this morning
live your life my story of loving and
losing nick cordell
cordero will be on sale tomorrow